et voici maintenant quelqu'un qui manque
complètement de toupet pourtant c'est un
maître ès provocations
le professeur chaud
est-ce provocation maître ès
provocations tu veux je met ta [ __ ] dans
le champagne pas encore à la fin tout à
l'heure
c'est vrai que son certificat d'études
en 11 ans oui c'est exceptionnel à
l'époque c'était 14 7 et 14 et j'ai une
dispense et c'était à l'époque du
maréchal pétain et le maréchal pétain
m'a envoyé une lettre de félicitations
mon cher enfant je vous félicite d'avoir
réussi et tout ça toi et donc à partir
de ce moment là j'ai chanté je sais moi
qui ai écrit la chanson maréchal nous
voilà c'est toi vrai trio touché au
genou voilà atteint là d'un attentat
dans dix mois alors à 15 ans tu es parti
faire le tour de france à 15 ans de
grandes et beaucoup de jeux à 15 ans tu
découvres la branlette
tu sais tu étais tout petits à l'école
ta petite kate tu l'as rome
tu l'as va monter tout doucement et puis
moi j'étais entouré de petites soeurs
tout le monde deux petites fentes qui
sentait bon l'ammoniac m
c'est vrai dit mais qu'est ce tu faisais
quand les histoires de france à 15 ans
c'est le tour de france c'est un vite
fait ouais
cette petite à france est un village
c'est comme si tu traverses le rutilent
à la grande rue dans la petite rue
l'hexagone et puis après je me suis dit
tiens je m'engage pour le gym s'est
engagé pour l'algérie est ce qui m'a plu
dans la 2 chine c'est que y'avait pas
d'appeler n'essaierai pas de gendarme
les mecs du contingent il y avait que
des voyous on tenait un l'indochine
c'était quatre fois la france et on
tenait sa avec 20000 voyous à l'époque
française après les américains ils ont
fui un millier llyod de gros crude
américain
nous on a tenu la tâche est favorable
quelques années avec khalil voyous en 55
rencontres caréna nom jean dada chine
jacques dans un hôpital militaire
tuberculeuse 100% insauvable c'est la
tuberculose c'est un poumon atteint
entendant les vins mais moi j'avais les
deux ouais qu'est ce qu'on fait mais je
me suis évadé l'hôpital c'est comme ça
j'ai guéri
j'étais condamné la terreur bien lorsque
tu fumes tout le temps a été donné
dimanche monsieur guéri avec l'alcool
j'ai un grand hommage à faire
aujourd'hui je vais profile dans
l'émission ardisson parce que il n'ya
pas beaucoup d'émissions comme la diam 1
ciara mais elles sont pas pareil que les
sketchs dit rien mais j'ai un grand et
un grand hommage rendre à l'alcool et au
tabac sans l'alcool et le tabac je ne
serais pas là je serai voir
c'est l'alcool le tabac et même
peut-être la veyron qui m'a sauvé jean
baucou hommage à la vérole et tout ça à
tous ces petits virus à tous et toutes
ces petites fantaisies conseils qu'on se
donne 1 et tous les gros quand titi qui
nous supprime ça qui m'a lancé travaux
l'eau du bois de boulogne vous rendez
compte c'est beau travelo du bois de
boulogne comme il était beau à paris on
n'est pas voir le tram c'est gargaud il
couvre la gueule comme ça et qui ne suce
même pas
en 1960 du fond de grille
c'est un accident ouais je rencontre
kavanagh je vendais des jours la rue tu
vois je rencontre carbone à reiser fret
au port machin et il m'a dit ray chante
que tu prends la recton pas quels
journaux sous droits viens avec nous tu
vas nous tu vas être d'autres éditeurs
et puis j'étais l'éditeur alors il ya eu
donc bal tragique à colombey le journal
était bien lancée les lundis soirs eu
des trois ports sont devenus des
rendez-vous obligé de tous les
dessinateurs et green elle est découpée
et des groupes et sa tirade y écoulent
alors explique moi comment ça se passe
et rapporte à la barre eu des trois
portes
c'est à la fin du jour n'ont donc ont
bouclé hier offre on bouche est vraiment
les trous ouais et du journal et des
groupes et qui veut nous voir
je me souviens d'une anecdote tu peux te
raconter la soul en tailleur tout ce que
tu veux
jean cau page je peux pas dire le nom
c'est un grand dessinateur de charlie
hebdo et il était et avait une grosse
[ __ ] va dire il avait une grosse truite
il avait une copine et une copie qui
faisait du porno au théâtre samia c'est
pour tenir pourtant et je ferme le
bureau tout le monde était parti sauf lé
mois et qui est elle ne prend à part et
me dit chan est ce que je peux te
demander un service à juillet ma chérie
comme tu veux et puis elle me dit si
j'aime je dit pas son nom
il est marié les enfants
mais d'un trop grosse [ __ ] est ce que tu
pourrais monthulé ce soir
je dis ma chérie moi j'ai une [ __ ]
normal ce sera un plaisir pour moi c'est
les anecdotes du bouclage de charlie et
même sa une que j'ai retenu sans censure
s'explique alors pour le moment en
dehors de tes mémoires tu fais un
journal pour les enfants de 4 à 7 ans
qui s'appelle gros dada qu'on a un
grenat
voilà alors parle-nous de gros dada ça
c'est ma nouvelle passion
alors tous tous les tous les lecteurs
qui ne connaissent il dit au chaud
connais tu as passé ta vie a fait rire
les groupes ont maintenant t'es fait
rire les petits cons ouais les gosses en
rafales et couche avec le négoce vouloir
payer grenade à y couche avec les
petites filles se branlent ans et tous y
couche avec ça y est cros dada c'est la
drogue et des petits îlots dont je suis
le fils de satan
je sais que papa mon temps dit